-Thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This first one is
from @bigmike199516.
Come on.
-Oh, @bigmike119515?
-No.
-Oh.
-This is @bigmike199516.
-Oh, I don't know that guy.
-Yeah.
-I don't know him.
-Yeah, there was --
-515?
-There was 199,515
other Big Mikes.
[ Laughter ]
He says, "My superpower would be
to able to replace all the air
in the bag of chips with chips."
There you go.
-Oh!
-Thank you. Finally!
Finally, Big Mike says it.
Tells it like it is.
-For humanity.
[ Light laughter ]
-This is -- Oh, come on.
This is from @ryanm5292.
-What?
-Are these Russian bots
or something?
[ Laughter ]
-They're hacking
"The Tonight Show" hashtag game.
[ Laughter ]
-What of it?
Hilary's e-mails?
-[ Russian accent ]
"This is my favorite bit.
I love when Jimmy Fallon
does the hashtag.
[ Laughs ]
I love his sense of humor."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] @ryanm5292.
-Oh.
-He says, "I think my superpower
would be to know what people's
dogs have named their owners."
Hey, there you go.
Smart.
[ Applause ]
-Flip it around, man.
-Flip it around, dude.
-This one is from
@hegartymatthew.
Is the last name?
Matthew Hegarty?
Yeah, it's like in the phone
book it would be --
-Yeah.
"Hegarty, Matthew?"
-"Here."
-"Here. Here sir."
[ Laughter ]
"Big Mike, 31543?"
"Here, sir."
[ Laughter ]
He says, "My superpower
would be to tell if
it's an actual emergency when
my wife yells, 'Oh, my God!'
from the other room.
Usually, it's about a show
on Investigation Discovery."
[ Applause ]
-What happened?
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @EquinsuOchaCA.
California --
Equinsu Ocha California maybe?
Maybe.
He says, "Caller I.D. allows us
to see who's calling.
My superpower would allow me
to see why they're calling."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
"Hey, I need a ride
to the airport.
It's your buddy,
Matthew Hegarty."
This one is from @gumgumerson
-Oh, I love @gumgumerson!
-He -- I think he's played
the game before.
-Yeah, many times.
-Thank you, Gum.
[ Laughter ]
-Gum rules, man.
He says, "I'd have the power
to turn my legs into ghost legs,
so I wouldn't have to get up
when someone was trying to walk
past my seat at
the movies or an event.
Just walk through me, bro.
It's cool.
I got ghost legs."
[ Applause ]
-Come on.
-Just ghosted out.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-This one is
from @MadisonGanglof.
She says, "I want the power
to switch bodies with my cat
so I can lay around all day
and he can take on
some responsibilities for once."
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get to work!
"Meow!"
-This one's from @Kristoffer.Er.
-Errrr.
-[ Russian accent ] Kristoffer.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Should be @Kristoffer3491246.
-3495678.
-Bot.
He says, "I want to be able
to turn every Alexa's voice into
Christopher Walken's."
-Yeah.
[ As Walken ]
-"The weather today will be --"
[ Normal voice ] This
last one is from @Brendathegoat.
[ Light laughter ]
-Greatest of all time.
Brenda,
the greatest of all time.
-Oh, there you go.
Yeah, the goat.
I got you.
-The goat.
-Greatest of all time.
I got ya.
Or could be --
-Or just a goat.
Could be a goat.
[ Laughter ]
[ Steve making goat calls ]
That's what the tweet is, yeah.
-It's a goat typing out stuff.
-Yeah.
@BrendaTheGoat, she says, "I
wish I could look in the mirror
and try any haircut.
Wish I'd done that last time.
Turns out I can't
pull off bangs."
There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
Check out more of our favorites.
Go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.